marie wolf dans son atelier très occupé
à transformer une matière première
assez inattendue alors là je découvre un
fonds de bouteilles avec de petits trous
que j'ai fait au fond le façon de
pouvoir y passer une perle
alors pourquoi le fond bouteille parce
que je trouvais que c'était assez écolo
pouvoir les récupérer et de pouvoir en
faire des bleus et parce que le fonds
des bouteilles ont déjà un relief qu'il
pouvait faire penser à une fleur entre
ses mains les bleus et prennent forme
une création originale le bleu est
devenu au fil du temps le symbole des
poilus de 14 18 le but et c'était déjà
une des fleurs avec le coquelicot qui
possède dans le champ de bataille sur
les champs de bataille clé quand même
assez extraordinaire et c'est aussi un
prêt un surnom que l'on donné aux roues
jeune soldat parce que eux est arrivé
c'était tout propre donc elles ont
retenu leur uniforme était bleue marine
wolf a lancé le concept puis les enfants
des écoles et de nombreux orléanais ont
réalisé leur propre bleus et chacun
porte d'ailleurs le nom de l'auteur est
celui d'un soldat
quand je vois tous ces prénoms je trouve
que c'est un grand hommage qui est fait
aux soldats et à leurs familles je suis
ravi et très honoré d'avoir pu créer ce
phénomène viret
des bleus et par milliers qui seront
installés sur le monument de la victoire
à orléans pour commémorer le centenaire
de l'armistice
[Musique]